Instead of using the device's exact
pixel density which can vary quite
a bit like 311 dpi or
442 dpi, Android groups devices
into a number of density buckets.
Each device gets assigned a density
bucket that most closely matches
its actual pixel density.
So a device with a 311 dpi screen
might get assigned 320 dpi or XHDPI,
and a device with a 442 dpi screen
might get assigned XXHDPI or 480 dpi.
Though there are density buckets for
both incredibly low density screens,
like 120 dpi, and really high density
screens, like 640 dpi, you generally
only have to work with the middle four
shown here, 160, 240, 320, and 480 dpi.
And these are sometimes
referred to as 1X, 2X, and 3X.
Now, these buckets give you control
over the scaling of your graphic assets,
things like icons.
They also ensure that you don't have to
create hundreds of different versions
of these little icons for
each screen's exact pixel density.
They essentially make your UI elements
almost exactly the same physical size,
like really, really close while
letting you only produce assets for
a handful of densities, these four.